you are a huge Taylor Swift fan yes
don't you guys love Taylor Swift Taylor
Swift I love her she's brilliant
here and she's the most popular singer
in the world right now and here's why I
like her there's so many disturbing
upsetting things happening in our world
right now in our country you know
internationally but Taylor Swift is
writing about the most important topic
which is what happens when your
boyfriend doesn't text you back
[Laughter]
essential cone you think she's getting
to the heart of the matter Lee and I
love her and I actually wrote a song I
wanted her to record which I think
sounds a lot like a Taylor Swift song
it's called glittering ribs and I made a
video for it that's online it's like a
Taylor Swift ballad but she hasn't
recorded it yet so I actually recorded
it alright so you wrote a song for
Taylor Swift and you think actually if
she hears about this song she might
record it yeah it really does sound like
a twit Taylor Swift song I wrote the
music and the lyrics yeah I would love
to hear that song is there any chance
you could sing it for us oh I would you
let me hear that okay yeah let's do it
yes
thank you for convincing me ponen okay
so like I said this is a song I wrote
for Taylor Swift to sing it's from her
point of view it's a song I like to call
glitter and ribs
[Music]
he was a boy I was a girl what more do
you need to know he was a boy he walked
through the door he was a door walking
through boy and with burgers on the
grill and sparkles on my eyes he served
me a favor where the side of life and we
made out while wearing bibs which
someone told me life won't always be
glitter and ribs glitter and glitter and
glitter and glitter and ribs and I don't
wanna buy ice cream just to watch it
melt and you can't
me I wasn't feeling the feelings I felt
and I don't wanna get married just to
get divorced and I don't wanna play golf
without a course so I'm running free but
I got a heart like a horse I never know
my heart like my heart knows my home
you never know my heart like my heart
knows like a boy's heart like a horn
like a my cup
like a horse
ha
[Music]
and looking back hoping with meaningless
I should have known that I'd be late but
I was only 16 and you were 14 ah stop
laughing haven't finished yet wish
someone told me life won't always be
littering
[Music]
[Applause]
you